hello everybody and welcome to episode
or part rather 13 of let's play penumbra
the Black Plague I'm about to be scared
like a itty bitty girl cuz I know I just
know there are doggies around here
somewhere oh no huh and something else I
think a guy named frisk oh yeah oh oh oh
no what is it - what okay turn it off
would that do oh no and the lights oh I
forget I forget which one was the
original state I'll turn them off I'm so
brave
oh look at me oh oh no no no no no yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] oh ok
turn the light on
screw that oh man oh what the [ __ ]
hell
Oh what the hell oh what the effing ass
Oh F the bat Oh F that hardcore oh man
huh
Oh oh no oh no oh no oh poor doggies
oh no oh they're even worse than doggies
oh no oh no they're mutated cuz oh no oh
what is that what is it oh I don't like
this oh but I'm brave oh [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you game
oh [ __ ] you huh uh-uh okay all right I'm
brave
I got a barrel oh oh I don't like this I
don't like this I like this I don't like
it I don't like it I don't like it
oh I don't like this oh this is bad okay
all right I think I have to turn the
lights off it's something to happen oh
no oh god no oh god I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't wanna I don't wanna
I don't I don't I don't wanna I don't
know I don't wanna I don't wanna
you can't make me I don't wanna oh I
don't want to if I move forward I'm
gonna die it just it kills me like
nobody's business
Oh
oh there's something there oh [ __ ] off
alright alright I'm tougher than this
guys oh I'm tougher than this ah I gotta
get me oh come on oh uh okay
lights off I mean lights on lights on
all lights on and let me let me turn the
lights off trigger it and then not do it
on the lights
Oh something crawling inside the wall Oh
after that f that
Oh F that okay lights are on can't get
me the light oh let go away go away go
away you too you too go away all right
I'm just wondering if it got me before I
did this Jen they have I don't know I
don't know okay
it's already counted this I think
horrible I know
aah oh god damn it
death [ __ ] come in oh okay
oh it's oh that's ID Oh dark marks god
oh oh I do not like this all I want to
get out of here
I just Oh what the what the hell oh I
want to get out of here well I don't
want to be here why did I come here the
reason Oh dog food Wow Oh godly cuca you
like must be program huh dangerous throw
yourselves him first [ __ ] ah student
become seriously decent oh here good
all batteries okay
ah no no it wouldn't
I'm not nearly stupid enough to oh man I
hate this need to light up the dark
corridor kennel somehow I don't know oh
oh I know I know oh I know oh I turned
the light turns off in here but turns
out over there I got to block it up with
these oh yeah oh ha so smart I'll take
this monsters you can't scare me
oh oh oh no oh no ok all right
this is totally it is it is it ah good
ok get ah get it totally sealed I'm not
quite little bit no more okay okay
alright
there we go yeah yeah oh yeah you are so
bad oh I wasn't even a little scared
not even a little bit I'll stop spinning
why is everything spin Oh jiminy
Christmas
oh good sealing you up good
oh man I hate that oh please work I
gotta say before I do Boop maybe unless
is taking my soul away from me I don't
know I don't know maybe I shouldn't
touch this okay all right Oh Joe oh ah
oh yeah yeah Oh who's the man answer is
I am markiplier
for laughs oh yeah save burp oh yeah oh
there's no lights there's no lights
weren't any lights
oh yeah there we go ah oh [ __ ] no Oh
balls
Boop oh no no no
okay I just gotta wait till lights come
on come on
do I flash I have enough last night okay
alright okay here they come
oh good golly Miss Molly ho I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
Oh Oh was there one more round the
corner aah aah Oh aah okay okay okay
here we go guys
ah I'm ready bring it on
oh yeah I'll wait for this one foodies
Oh gon win I'll win I win another one oh
yeah Oh gimme gimme
give me my prize my process a dead guy
Oh block you up I'll [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off so hard oh good gracious
Jimmy who are you what is this
alright Hey Oh what the hell happened to
good old [ __ ] [ __ ] no don't change
something that's what I want to know
don't chase don't change anything
don't change anything oh don't change
something what did you change
did you change Oh doggy
Oh doggy please oh it's so dark
Oh God oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no no
okay all right I got this I got this I
got this I got this I got it oh oh yeah
I got it I got it I got it
oh oh huh cut it yeah all right yeah
yeah oh yeah oh so great oh I'm the best
I'm the best oh look at me up not aa big
brain muscles a braveness juice
everywhere oh yeah oh yeah oh oh yeah oh
wanna let it right a few home hours make
a really appreciate this
oh shut up rescue attempt hello rescue
I'm a gecko right never big ha make the
most of her what she's fun or I'll shut
up you next nudge oh you big pervert I
was just gonna you know totally rescue
her for not ah I did good good get away
Oh fu man I'm tired I'm sick and tired
go away yeah f o fo was it aa dead end
Oh get away get away get away
hi what do you think you're doing Oh
what up Pro Dodge
uh oh let's see a box going pop no not
gonna happen
alright I got a key card I got a key
card I got a key card
I got a kicker oh go go ah ah I put in a
duck duck yeah oh yeah yeah oh hello
baby
Emily oh where ya at Baby I'll see you
let's go oh yeah shelter Research
Station is encountering technical
difficulties please have your personal
cyanide capsule at the ready huh yep
okay I have to cut here real quick but
we'll get to awesome hogging quota I'm
making air quotes hugging time in the
next episode see you in part 14 thanks
for watching bye bye